I can tell by your faces that many of
you are shocked at the outcome I on the
other hand am not because I have had The
Misfortune of teaching you this semester
and even with my ocular limitations I
witness firsthand your Glazed
uncomprehending
Expressions sir I don't understand
that's glaringly apparent thank you so
much for being here and congratulations
on such a beautiful funny human movie um
I want to start with Alexander because I
understand you've sort of been mulling
over a story like this or a story about
boarding schools for years uh can you
tell me sort of the initial spark or
inspiration for the holdovers the idea
came from my viewing of a 1935 French
film by Marcel panol and it had the same
general uh premise not the same story
but the same premise and I thought
that's a good idea for a
movie and then I got a screenplay from
this
guy for a pilot about five years ago uh
set at a boarding
school and I thought aha let me call him
up and see if maybe he could get a draft
going of this SC of this story so I
called him up asked him if he would do
it he said yes God bless him and here it
is and at what point did you realize
that this wasn't a joke and Alex I
thought it was a joke thank you for
mentioning that I have a buddy of mine
who likes to call me up and pretend to
be various creative luminaries no yeah I
know I was shooting a TV show over in
Prague and I've been flying a lot and I
was dog tired to the point of delirium
and I got this call and I was about to
curse him out lovingly and hang up the
phone and I noticed the Omaha area code
and I was like all you're you're
Alexander Payne wow you really are he
goes yeah yeah yeah so um
that that flowed from that and he sort
of as a threshold matter mentioned this
and I I I mean I jumped on it
immediately I think immediately can you
tell us a little more though about the
process of building these really complex
characters because the movie is so
character-driven uh yeah you know I mean
as Alexander rightly pointed out he had
this this sort of log line which was
kind of ocularly challenged kind of
odiferous Professor you know yeah
odiferous and he's punished in just
staying there and there's this one kid
whose mom you know stranded him and
that's kind of what what we both knew
and then I started thinking about well
okay I definitely know the world of
these kids I understand the universe of
these boys I was one I remember it six
years vividly etched into my memory
burned into my memory I said you know I
think I want to kind of peel off those
other kids and I just want to focus on
three people um and basically I was
mining my uncle who raised me who was an
extraordinary guy and this incredibly
Vivid kind of barok profane person who
was just just a ferocious genius he was
just a great interesting autodidact
amazing guy my mom who was an incredibly
loving hardworking woman and my dad who
taught at a prep school who actually
never graduated from high school ended
up in in the Merchant Marine World War
II and ended up at Yale in the GI bill
so I kind of used my personal history to
to frame it and uh Kevin you've been
working with Alexander since citizen
Ruth correct going all the way back to
the beginning maybe even further back
than that if there were student films or
anything um what secret to such a
successful ongoing collaboration I think
we're we're similar in some respects we
have similar tastes and uh I grew up in
Buffalo New York you grew up in Omaha I
think there's similar Midwestern we're
like sister cities yeah yeah and I don't
know we just always we got along when we
first met and uh and we work really hard
but we he's wonderful to work with and
as anyone will tell you and uh he makes
it fun and I like that too I think I've
been that I was that that way even
before I you know I'd love to work with
a different editor but his wife would
kill
me that's
[Laughter]
true um you know they talk about
directors and actors having a short hand
but I have to imagine you two must edit
relatively fast for for filmmakers he's
super slow
really he's really
slow we're both slow we're both slow
we're meticulous we're meticulous
meticulous is a better word for us yes
we're very meticulous we go over things
if people saw the minutia and
discussions we go into about certain
little things theyd think we're crazy
probably but but God is in the details
yes we have to talk about this amazing
cast because every single role is so
well cast um but I'm curious did you did
you go to Paul gamat and say ocularly
challenged and odiferous and I want
you I personally did not say that
no the pitch was a little little warmer
than that well I was just in the
screenplay that he he has a wonky eye
and um then it comes out later he smells
bad and it was written with him in mind
absolutely so it it's a threshold
conversation I mean when we first
started talking I mean I think if not
the first conversation the second he was
like how do you feel about Paul gmati
and I said I love Paul Gatti and so
that's why the character's name is Paul
I mean I Taylor made this for him with
you know Alexander sitting beside me we
talked about it at the length and I
would send him drafts and and the thing
about Paul is he's so incredibly
expressive you see like five thoughts
cross his mind just in his eyes and his
face he just incredible Paul Gatti is a
great artist he is when handing him a
role like this it's like giving a part
to Merill Streep or Ralph Richardson or
you know like I don't I'm not going to
sweat at all what he's going to do with
the part I give him the part and I'm
just dying of curiosity to see what he's
going to do with it you it's like I I'm
then a film Watcher just watching him do
it it could be a little bit more like
this or that but whatever it is whatever
he's going to do is going to be great
he's creating that it's really fun to
watch Kevin I'm jealous of you because
you get to see so many different takes
of these performances well I can say
this about Paul's performance too and I
said this the other night too he I mean
you wrote some real tongue twisters for
but he just nailed them all the time and
I mean maybe once or twice I can think
where he had to step back and go wait
wait let me go back and get that again
there are very few actors that I think
of who could hold their own with Paul
Giamatti and so you went out and found
one in Dominic cessa who is just
incredible the kid the who plays Angus
yes the kid this guy had never been in
front of a camera before he was so he
was an actual uh senior at Deerfield
Academy playing a junior at basically
Deerfield Academy and we were shooting
at Deerfield Academy and this after the
casting director fielded about 800
submissions for that part of which I saw
maybe 10% of that and uh so we wound up
calling up the schools where I actually
was going to be
shooting you know cont contact the Drama
teacher and uh there he was I picked up
two actors from Deerfield him and the
blonde kid in the opening scene who goes
oh I eat that cob salad that's great so
he was an actual Junior at at Deerfield
I can think of so many actors that I
feel you discovered or at least
introduced us to um how did you develop
this amazing eye for
talent oh well you're not ocularly
challenged when to Talent thank you and
I I don't pay myself many compliments in
film making but I do think uh I've had
some pretty good luck with casting
because it's the most important thing
and you know a movie can be anything but
in the types of movies were concerned
with you know basically 2hour narrative
commercial is uh feature films the most
important things are screenplay and
casting sometimes you just think the
gods are with you and finding this kid
Dominic cessa who had never been in
front of a camera and then wasn't just a
good actor but a good film actor yeah
like he had the right relaxation and and
he was very good technically I I want
him to feel really real like they're
really the right age and really in high
school and you meet the kind of
Hollywood kids the star kids who are on
some TV show or some hit movie or
something and they're too
polished and then you look at
nonprofessional actors or non-actors and
they might have an interesting like
Spirit or face but maybe aren't going to
be bulletproof is the word I use when
when we start shooting so it just takes
time Divine Joy Randolph here I knew she
would be funny she is utterly
heartbreaking she's such an accomplished
actor on stage do you audition someone
like that or do you just know both so
first of all Divine like Paul got her
MFA in acting at
Yale and I had seen her in um Dolomite
is my name a very fine motion picture
and she kind of steals a lot of the
scenes she's in with Eddie Murphy hard
to do but she did it and uh when I went
to start meeting actresses to play that
part I asked for her by name wow but I
typically like to use actors with comic
chops in atic Parts I thought she maybe
she could do it the holdovers feels like
it was a movie made in the' 70s with the
music and the whole production design
what were some of the other ways you
reinforce this 70s feel also in the
editing and in the writing I wanted this
to have the feel that we were that we
had made a lowbudget film in 1970 with
largely found locations we're not making
a period film we're doing an exercise of
making a contemporary film set in 197
and then the DI process afterwards they
have many wonderful tools right now to
give it a genuine film filmic look in
our editing process we really approached
it like we do all our films our approach
didn't really change we we did what we
always did which is like I said really
let performances Drive our decisions in
The Cutting Room writing wise I just
sort of started saturating myself in
those movies in the hashy movies and Bob
R movies and Robert Alman movies and
Mish foran and Fran for Co like I just
sort of wanted to see how the what the
the humanist rhythms of those movies
were which were very different than a
lot of the cinema from the last 30 years
and I love them growing up and I
rediscovered them and I just sort of
tried to replicate that sort of gradual
reveal which is actually you know
present in every single one of his
movies I mean
Alexander you you learn about these
people through what they do and how they
react and their shameful Secrets emerge
and their passions so I was very
interested in kind of like replicating
that 70s humanist feel and I really
tried hard to do that obviously there's
this wonderful dialogue ever like penis
cancer in human form I'll be saying till
the end of my life um but there's so
much found in the silences in the things
that go unsaid um can you talk about you
know sort of choosing to utilize that
silence this man judiciously and wisely
was constantly about he he refers to
something called emotional break fluid
where like what is stopping and starting
the character and what I discovered was
often times the silences and the
freighted silences the weighted silences
judiciously employed you know and I was
like thinking about my my youngest son
is uh studies animation right now and he
loves Miyazaki you know and Miyazaki has
this concept of ma this idea of ma which
is like silence in an animated film you
know in which it's all kind of whole
cloth but when I was talking to my
20-year-old son and and he was watching
Miyazaki I'm like I want to use that
technique the really cool thing is that
this movie is now playing in theaters so
you can all go out and see it again and
again um and it goes wide on November
10th um please spread the word it's such
a special film thank you so much for
being a great a thank you very much
thank you thank you thanks everybody
thanks very much thanks for
coming